LOUIS GRAY: The most epic films
are made into trilogies,
and that's no different here
at Google Developers Live.
I'm excited to host Googler
Brian Fitzpatrick, or as I
call him, Fitz, a world champion
for users and data
for a series of shows starting
this Tuesday at 3:00 PM
Pacific, when we sit down and
talk about the human element
of business and office
politics, tackling
organizational manipulation.
On Wednesday, we'll be back
at the same time, 3:00 PM,
talking about the data
liberation front, fighting the
good fight to help you own your
data, and if you'd like,
to get it out of Google if
you decide to leave.
Fitz and I also believe
transparency is a
core value at Google.
That's the topic of the finale
this Thursday at 10:30 AM,
taking a deep dive into the
Google Transparency Report,
showing our users how global
politics can sometimes get in
the way of you getting
to our sites.
Fitz is no typical engineer, and
these are no typical GDL
events, so make sure
you don't miss out.
Subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube, or add these
events to your calendar at
developers.google.com/live.
This has been Louis Gray from
Google Developers Live, and
I'll see you in the studio.